I just want to start with the news that
many people switch on their TVs this
morning to discover and Caroline Flack
found dead the former presenter of love
island now of course she was arrested
and charged with assault
before reportedly taking her own life
how careful do you think the Crown
Prosecution Service needs to be when
dealing with individuals who are clearly
vulnerable well first of all given that
somebody has died here to pass on my
thoughts and I'm sure many people
watching this will be sad here's
somebody only 40 years old being lost
like this of course there was a duty of
care for everybody involved in in these
things but I think we'd be pretty
careful at this stage we don't know the
circumstances as yet and you know
there's obviously quite a a bit more to
the background to this in terms of as
you say there was a little ongoing CPS
work but but look I don't want to jump
in and and and complicate what it is
already a complex situation yeah that is
then of course very understandable and
at the same time this is the third death
linked to love island after two former
contestants also took their lives after
appearing on the show is that a cause
for concern do you think that love
island should still go ahead well I do
think that you know there clearly you
know people making these programs do
have that sort of duty of care not just
a contestants but as we've seen two
presenters as well but I don't want to
jump to conclusions here because there
may be that we know there are other
circumstances involved in this Caroline
Flack case so you know let's wait and
see but yes of course I mean there's
always be a duty of care and by the way
also you know online harms and we know
that or think we know that social media
and you know potential of all the things
which have been talked about so much
this past few weeks months and years of
online bullying and things like that can
play a part so you know the government's
doing its bit with that consultation
would launch in the week but of course
as the duty of care but I think beyond
that it's difficult to sort of comment
without
the facts here yeah actually say very
kind of complex and sad story this
morning
I'm looking to move on to storm Dennis
something else that is gonna be
affecting many of our viewers this
morning and you of course as transport
secretary can be very across the
disruption that the storm is causing and
could potentially still courts is the UK
really equipped to deal with these kind
of weather conditions we certainly seem
to be getting more of these extreme
weather conditions and we mean we all
know the reasons in the background to
that but actually the UK is also
stepping up its response so I was having
a looking at the homes flooded is
incredibly sad it disrupts people's
lives beyond all belief and some people
are having their lives disrupted time
and time again I was looking at the
figures 800 homes have been flooded
since last Friday and so that's
obviously tragic 23,000 homes that would
have otherwise been flooded have
actually been protected by these storm
these and those measures that have been
put in place and the government's sort
of put 2.4 billion pounds into
protection up until next year for the
six years up until next year but to give
you a sort of idea of the scale of what
we want to do now we're putting another
4 billion pounds in place for the next
six year period so we're really
massively increasing the spending on
storm defense and flood defences which I
absolutely the right thing to do people
will have seen the pictures on your
program of the army pitching in there in
in Yorkshire and elsewhere today which
is really important for the whole you
know the whole machinery of government
acts to try to protect people's homes
but it is a fact of climate change that
we will have to do more going forward
yeah of course you're keen to emphasize
what the government is doing the money
that you're putting in but as you say
these extreme weather conditions do seem
to be coming more regular more normal
you know storm carers already kind of
wrecked many people's homes and storm
Dennis now giving others a battering I
mean some of these areas particularly in
Yorkshire were promised much more help
back in 2015 when then there were floods
there some will be thinking that if this
kind of thing was happening in London it
wouldn't take him so long for the help
to reach the areas well I think in a
sense you know if the weather
is extremely these things can never come
fast enough I mean that's absolutely
true and you're right more helpers
promise I think in 2015 that skin got
designed quite quickly in 2017 and it's
due to be delivered finished in 2021
it's not behind its schedule or anything
these are just massive and very complex
schemes to deliver as well but as I
mentioned you know 23,000 homes have
been protected in the in the last week
that wouldn't have been if some of the
other measures hadn't taken place but
every single home that's flooded you
know its make no bones about it is a
complete tragedy it just I visited the
homes of people who've been affected by
storms and floods in the past and it is
just a complete tragedy it's it's sort
of you know but because it is your home
it's it can really really you know
affect your life in a very very
significant way and what the government
wants to do is as much as as possible
which is why as I say that the budgets
going up to four billion from from 2.4
billion for the next period and all of
this works on going on some very big
complex engineering projects okay and
I'm keen to touch as well we've got you
about story that's on the front page of
The Sunday Times this morning now this
is reporting number 10 aides saying that
they're not bluffing about scrapping the
BBC licence fee and replacing it with a
subscription and saying that the BBC
should be pruned back I mean is that
true is that really what number 10
thinks I'd be pretty cautious of
servants I'm unattributed comments I
mean what we're here are the facts we
know you know the world's changing we
live in a sort of Netflix world where
people do more and more you know put the
TV on when they want to and watch what
they want when they want to and that
sort of thing
obviously the BBC's got to change but we
know that there's a there's a
consultation out there it's primarily
focused around things like whether it
should be a criminal offence not to pay
a license fee or whether it should be
treated the same as all other utilities
which of course you still have to pay
your your water bill or or what-have-you
but it's just a consultation at this
stage and then no further decisions made
at all running away a bit because you
say that it's consultation but many
people picking up the copy the
at Sunday Times this morning we think
that actually it's a consultation to
which number 10 has already decided the
answer to I don't think that's that's
right you're like you know I I don't
want to say that not everything in the
newspaper is always necessarily 100
percent correct and it still makes the
front page exactly but you know the BBC
is I would say a much-loved national
treasure we all want it to be a huge
success but everybody including the BBC
themselves recognize than in a changing
world
you know the BBC itself will have to
change I mean that's just a fact of life
but it's simply not the case that
there's some pre-orders at Dane decision
about the future funding of the BBC out
there buffin anything else by the way
this charter runs to 2027 so there's a
long way to go on all these things and
certainly no decisions that's the point
of a consultation okay now of course
there very fact that you're talking to
us this morning Lisa you kept your job
in the reshuffle last week
congratulations someone not quite so
lucky was the Chancellor such a Javid
who quit after number 10 demanded that
he sack all of the aides and set up a
joint economic unit between number 10
and number 11 I mean this sounds like a
paragraph doesn't it well first of all I
just want to say of Sajid Javid and it's
a great colleague and I thought he was
doing a good job as Chancellor and it
had a string of very high-profile jobs
before that Home Secretary etc but in
the embassy
I suspect viewers are probably watching
this conversation again yeah I would
expect that everybody all the advisers
are certainly my advisers in transport I
want them to be working hand in glove
this is an incredibly ambitious
government that wants to deliver stuff
for people
if I just work hand in glove with number
10 he was told to sack I wasn't in the I
wasn't in the room you know nor were you
but what I do think is that it's a good
thing to have in certainly the way that
my special advisers work is I want them
to be working closely with number 10 I
want them to be delivering the same
policy and we've got this massive sort
of agenda of leveling up the country and
uniting the country and that's best done
when you're all on the same page and
singing from the same hymn sheet so you
know I've no doubt at all that in terms
of making you
but people really care about in my case
transport things if we can get the
trains running on time they've got a lot
to do to do that etc we're gonna level
up then you'd expect us to all be
wanting the same thing and not have
different silos and different locations
so so you know more to the good I think
if we can get this government delivering
for people every single day of the week
by everybody being on the same page so
if you had gone into your meeting with
Boyce Johnson last week and he'd ask you
to sack all of your advisors would
you've gone along with it well here's
the thing you know primarily I work with
you know the Prime Minister and others
of course you you you have some advisors
who work with each other to celina
things up a across government policy and
that's perfectly right and normal and
proper but I'd be pretty concerned if my
advisors weren't working hand-in-glove
that would be a concern to me let alone
to number ten I want to get things
delivered for this country and that's
what this government is pushing on and
doing which is new exciting project with
five years to go and I want us all to be
working in the same direction okay now
according to reports and I know that
you'll probably say you can't believe
everything that you read in the papers
but certainly coming from somewhere
Sajid Javid clashed with Dominic
Cummings and the Prime Minister's chief
aide now when I speak to Kay stahma and
we'll hear the full interview at later
in the show he said the Prime Minister's
Questions should be renamed DC Q's
Dominic Cummings questions because he's
really the person who's running number
10 I mean is he actually running the
show here's where that why that's just
not correct I find with all the Prime
Minister's invite advisors Dominic
coming included and they're there to
provide advice to you know provide
challenge if you like and you know have
a have a good debate about things but
it's not the case that things
necessarily go Domenic coming his way or
anyone else and take HS to this last
week is a big decision
the Dominic will have had views about I
had views about you know in the end
about always have sorry second did you
clash with him on it then flashes is the
wrong way to describe but we discussed
it we discussed our varying views and we
came to a conclusion but the idea that
you know just because Dominic things
something that's what happens is clearly
not the case
as in
in this example but it doesn't mean that
you clash with or fall out with or
whatever I value the advice the Prime
Minister values the the advice and we
come to better decisions by making sure
we were analyzing all the data and
particularly in the case of something
like HS 2 which was this enormous
infrastructure decision for this country
that took a lot of analysis and a lot of
data why would you not want people who
are going hold on that's interesting why
don't we get more information why let me
look at it differently but you know in
the end yeah we come to a decision and
we collectively agree to it and as I say
just to sort of challenge your your your
assertion it's not the case that it
should be p.m. whatever you call it DS
but because actually we we are perfectly
capable of coming to conclusions which
benefit everybody in this this country
and that that's what we're trying to do
as a government big ambitious projects
as well as things which we'll complete
within the five years of this Parliament
so people see real improvements to their
lives particularly my case within the
transport area that right across
government and having good people to
advise as great that advisors advise and
ministers decide talking about advisors
and in the mail on Sunday today and
Russa Biscay a new Downing Street
advisor according to the newspaper had a
couple of pretty controversial public
comments that he made back in 2014
including saying one way to get around
the problems of unplanned pregnancy is
creating a permanent underclass would be
to legally enforce universal uptake of
long-term contraception at the onset of
puberty he also said it's still unclear
to what extent female genital mutilation
represents a serious risk to young girls
and women's sport is more comparable to
the Paralympics than it is to men's is
that the kind of person you want in
number 10 well I'm afraid I not only
have I not seen the story I don't
actually know the individual you're
referring to at all so I'm afraid our
I'll probably have to disappoint you by
not providing a commentary on any of
that I haven't seen heard about that at
all would you be concerned no some who
had said those views publicly in the
past was working number 10
you you're enticing me so I asking me
the same question again I I simply
haven't seen this I don't know the
individual but clearly not views that
either I or the government itself shares
in any way shape or form but I don't I
don't have the facts I don't want to
just shoot from the hip on this one okay
now a couple just to finish on the
reshuffle you know that we've seen the
number of women in cabinet has gone down
as a result of it the number of people
educated in private schools has gone up
as a result the number of people from
ethnic minority but backgrounds has also
gone down does that matter are you
worried about not having a cabinet
that's representative of the people well
I think you're talking about ones and
twos levels here but what you've
forgotten to mention is the the number
of parliamentary Undersecretary of State
now that's the vast majority of
ministers in this government and the
most easy u.s. is there no in most union
but it's also the most ministers as well
for the first time ever in British
history 50 50 of those are women to men
so we've made a huge step forward and
you know in terms of diversity in
cabinet this is still the most diverse
cabinet that we've ever had apart from
the last one I mean it's absolutely not
the case that there's some sort of big
reversal there and what's happening of
course is because we've now got 50
percent women those as you rightly say
the lower rung of the minister or ladder
but nonetheless where most of the
ministers actually sit it means that
they can clearly come through the best
of those people will be future cabinet
ministers and who knows perhaps to the
third female prime minister in this
country and I think it's interesting and
revealing that it's always the
Conservative Party that has had women
prime ministers and that weird you know
at this point in time with half of all
of our junior ministers now women is
it's I think it bodes well for the
future quickly to end after all the
drama at the last week as the budgets
still going to go ahead as planned on
March 11th well I know that the budget
plans are well advanced but I also know
that research cineq the the new
chancellor may want time he has I
haven't heard whether the the date of
March is confirmed as yet he's probably
looking at it I should think this this
week so I'll leave it to the Treasury to
announce that but I just have to say
she who is now Chancellor was a
fantastic a chief secretary to the
Treasury that's the position that he's
come from previously we worked with him
very closely he'll be a terrific
Chancellor of the Exchequer I think and
whenever the budget is I'm sure it will
be a huge success for this country and
we're really going to spend the next few
weeks months and years levelling up this
country and really trying to do the
things that people want in return for
them having trusted us with their
support which we appreciate it's been
lent to us and we intend to deliver on
it